welche farbe hat der rucksack welche
farbe hat der rucksack er ist grün
er ist grün
welche farbe haben die schuhe
sie sind braun
braun wie viel kostet das kleid wie
hier kostet das kleid es kostet 149
franken
es kostet 149 franken
wie viel kostet der pullover
wie viel kostet der pullover er kostet
87 franken
er kostet 87 franken
wie viel kostet die schere
wie viel kostet die schere sie kostet 6
franken 80
sie kostet 6 franken 80
hier ist ein schlüssel
hier ist ein schlüssel ist das dein
schlüssel ist das dein schlüssel
nein das ist nicht mein schlüssel
nein das ist nicht mein schlüssel welche
farbe hat der schlüssel
welche farbe hat der schlüssel
er ist blau
hier ist eine jacke hier ist eine jacke
ist das deine jacke ist das
deine jacke nein das ist nicht meine
jacke nein das ist nicht meine jacke
[Musik]
welche farbe hat die jacke welche farbe
hat die jacke sie ist rot sie ist rot
ein helm die hier ist ein helm die ist
das dein handy ist das dein handy nein
das ist nicht mein handy nein das ist
nicht mein handy welche farbe hat das
handy welche farbe hat das handy es ist
schwarz es ist schwarz was man
hast du gern was machst du gern ich
schwimme gerne ich schwimme gerne ich
tanze gern ich tanze gern spielst du
gern fußball spielst du gern fußball
ja ich spiele gern fußball
nein ich spiele nicht gern fußball
ich spiele nicht gern fußball was machst
du nicht gern
was machst du nicht gern
ich putze nicht gern
ich habe
sie nicht gern ich arbeite nicht gern
ich koche nicht gern
ich gehe ins kino
ich putze die wohnung
hilfst du mir hilfst du mir ja ich helfe
dir ja ich helfe dir
nein ich helfe dir nicht nein ich helfe
dir nicht
fährst du gern beelow fährst du gern
velo ja ich fahre gern wie du ja ich
fahre gern will nein ich fahre nicht
gern will nein ich fahre nicht gern will
gibst du mir deine handynummer gibst du
mir deine handynummer
ja ich gebe dir meine handynummer
nein ich gebe dir meine handynummer
nicht nein ich gebe dir meine
handynummer nicht hast du kinder hast du
kinder ja ich habe kinder ja ich habe
kinder
ich habe keine kinder nein ich habe
keine kinder
ich laufe immer am mittwoch am abend im
park ich laufe immer am mittwoch am
abend im park jeden freitag treffe ich
nach der arbeit freunde jeden freitag
treffe ich nach der arbeit freunde
wir gehen in eine bar wir gehen in eine
bar machst du oft sport machst du oft
sport ja ich mache oft sport ja ich
mache oft sport nein ich mache selten
sport
nein
ich mache selten sport brauchst du
brauchst du ja ich brauche manchmal ja
ich rauche manchmal nein ich brauche
nicht nein ich rauche nicht isst du
gesund isst du gesund
ja ich esse meistens gesund ja ich esse
meistens gesund nein ich esse selten
gesund nein ich esse selten gesund
wann beginnt der film wann beginnt der
film der film beginnt um 18 uhr 15
der film beginnt um 18 uhr 15
ist am montag
termin frei ist
noch einen termin frei am montag ist
noch ein termin frei
am montag ist noch ein termin frei
nein am montag ist kein termin mehr frei
wann ist ein arzttermin
wann ist ein arzttermin mein termin ist
am montag um 9 uhr 30
mein termin ist am montag um 9 uhr 30
bis 2
hat der supermarkt geöffnet bis man hat
der supermarkt geöffnet der supermarkt
hat bis 19 uhr 30 geöffnet
der supermarkt hat bis 19 uhr 30
geöffnet
kannst du gut kochen kannst du gut
kochen ja ich kann sehr gut kochen ja
ich kann sehr gut kochen
nein ich kann nicht gut kochen
kannst du gitarre spielen kannst du
gitarre spielen
ja ich kann gitarre spielen
nein ich kann nicht gitarre spielen
dann stehst du am morgen auf wann stehst
du am morgen auf ich stehe um zwanzig
nach sechs auf ich stehe um zwanzig nach
6 auf was ziehst du für die party an was
ziehst du für die party an
ich ziehe ein kleid an
[Musik]
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal